If you plan on going into Avengers: Endgame
completely spoiler-free, well best of luck
to you.
But if you really just can't wait for your
next Endgame fix, these leaks and spoilers
should tide you over until April.
Sometimes it isn't what a Marvel actor says
that gives the game away, but where they say
it.
In August 2018, fans noticed that a certain
behind-the-scenes interview with Robert Downey
Jr. seemed to take place on the set of Shuri's
lab in Wakanda.
Taking this at face value, it would seem to
imply that Tony Stark is going to Wakanda
— and could meet the young Wakandan genius
herself.
The second Endgame trailer revealed what we
all knew was going to happen - Tony Stark
makes it back to Earth.
Once home, it looks like he and Shuri could
combine their considerable brainpower and
scientific know-how to give the Avengers a
chance to put things right.
Unfortunately, Marvel threw a curveball during
the Endgame trailer by having Shuri's face
flash up on one of Bruce Banner's monitors,
implying that she was lost during the Decimation.
This is despite Angela Bassett, who plays
Queen Ramonda, having already confirmed to
ScreenRant that she and Shuri both survived.
Obviously Thanos will return in Endgame but
will he really be the lead villain?
Long before Avengers 4 had even been given
a title, tie-in merch for the movie seemed
to drop a potentially huge spoiler for the
story.
The packaging, which showed Thor and Rocket
Raccoon kitted out with brand new matching
costumes, included a short synopsis that seemingly
confirmed a new villain would come to the
fore in Endgame.
It read:
"The Asgardian Thor wields the mighty Stormbreaker
in his battle against new foes.
Rocket teams up with a new crew to guard the
galaxy from an even greater threat."
“Aw, what the hell.
I don’t got that long a lifespan anyway.”
But who or what could this "greater threat"
be?
If Endgame follows the plot of the Infinity
Gauntlet comic, Nebula could end up as the
main antagonist but there are a whole host
of other villains who could end up facing
down the Avengers.
Of course, it’s entirely possible that Thanos
is the primary villain for Endgame after all,
and that this “greater threat” is a terrifying
new plan that he’s putting into action.
Who knows?
In October 2018, TheWrap exclusively revealed
that 13 Reasons Why star Katherine Langford
had joined the cast of the upcoming Avengers
sequel in a mystery role, and various other
media outlets quickly backed the story up.
The Hollywood Reporter later confirmed:
"Langford has filmed scenes for the currently
untitled Avengers 4.
Character details were not available, and
Marvel Studios had no comment."
MovieWeb sources claimed that Langford had
already finished all of her filming for the
movie, suggesting that she was brought on
board in a relatively minor role and did what
she needed to do during the September 2018
reshoots.
So Langford's part probably won't be a big
one, but if it was little more than glorified
extra work then Marvel wouldn't have gone
to the trouble of hiring an in-demand star.
She got a much-deserved nod at the Golden
Globes 2018 for her work as Hannah Baker in
teen drama 13 Reasons Why, the first season
of which was a massive hit for Netflix.
Marvel and Disney clearly know a rising star
when they see one, but just how important
Langford is to Endgame has yet to be seen.
Don Cheadle's Colonel James Rhodes was badly
injured during the events of Captain America:
Civil War, but Tony Stark's loyal Air Force
buddy came back from the brink of paralysis
to join the fight against Thanos in Infinity
War.
Rhodey was one of the few heroes who survived
the Mad Titan's mass genocide in that movie,
meaning he'll be among those who rally against
the villain in Endgame and he'll apparently
be doing so in some badass new armor.
Boom, you looking for this?”
Toy-related leaks have been coming thick and
fast as Endgame’s release draws ever closer,
and while the Russo brothers have insisted
that the vast majority of these toys are not
reflective of the movie's actual plot, the
sibling directors have been known to tell
little white lies in order to throw fans off
the scent.
Images of what appear to be official Endgame
LEGO sets are now online, and there's every
reason to believe they're the real deal.
One set that is already being sold in the
UK is titled “War Machine Buster”.
As the name suggests, it's a Hulkbuster style
version of Rhodey's War Machine armor.
This isn't official confirmation that we'll
see Rhodey in new, pimped-out armor during
Endgame, but the fact that the set also includes
War Machine and Ant-Man minifigures suggests
that we might indeed, since the two characters
are shown suiting up side-by-side in Endgame’s
Super Bowl TV spot.
Despite starring in 2011's Thor and its 2013
follow-up Thor: The Dark World, Natalie Portman's
Jane Foster was nowhere to be seen in the
trilogy’s wildly successful threequel, Thor:
Ragnarok.
“Sorry to hear that Jane dumped you.”
“She didn’t dump me, you know.
I dumped her.
it was a mutual dumping.”
Portman is said to have fallen out of love
with Marvel Studios during the course of the
much-maligned The Dark World, displeased that
future Wonder Woman director Patty Jenkins
was let go from the project.
But Marvel has changed since then, and so
has Portman's stance on the franchise.
When she spoke to ScreenRant in early 2018,
the Oscar winner revealed that she was actually
open to reprising the role in future movies,
though she hadn't heard anything from Marvel
at that time.
It seems the Russo brothers got this message
loud and clear, because when they were asked
about Foster's status post-Decimation by The
Huffington Post a few months later, they refused
to comment because it was a "potential spoiler,"
implying that the studio may still have plans
for the character going forward.
Of course, Foster is one of the MCU’s leading
astrophysicists, so her skill set would certainly
come in handy during Endgame.
But if nothing else, Jane and Thor could probably
both do with morale boost after the events
of Infinity War — and a reunion could be
just the thing they need.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Avengers:
Endgame are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.